we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here's an interesting
voicemail a guy recounted a conversation
he had with someone he works with I
believe
and there is such misunderstanding among
right Wingers about such basic things
listen to this voicemail and then we'll
discuss it okay
well David this is Bob from Texas yeah
uh I was having a conversation with a
co-worker or my manager I should say and
he was saying he was complaining about
um the covid relief
and saying that it affected his 401k and
how much he you know could put into it
or something like that
and oh man in I explained I told him
well Trump did two of them and you know
you should be doubly mad at him right
instead of biting you know and and I
just had I know I should probably do
some research on my own but
how does how does the covert relief
funds affect 401k and I know you're a
big Finance guy you may have some
insight on it yeah so listen here's the
first of all
a ton of the P so Trump has started
saying this at his rallies your 401ks
are doing terribly because of Biden what
does that really mean it's the stock
market okay when people talk about a
401k a 401k holds the same types of
assets anybody might hold directly so
it's stocks stock mutual funds Bond
mutual funds so re what they're really
saying is 401K balances go up and down
when the stock market goes up and down
so understand that the when they talk
about 401K what they really mean is the
stock market okay
what some right-wingers have claimed is
that covid relief packages
increased inflation and therefore pushed
down the value of the stock market so as
the caller points out if you're mad at
Biden for doing that with one coveted
relief package you should be doubly mad
at Trump for doing it with two the
reality is that the effect of those
coveted relief packages on global
markets in the American Market overall
is quite limited but I actually think
that's not even the right conversation
to have the right conversation is zoom
out and think for a second does the
stock market tend to do better when
there's a Democratic president or a
Republican president and the data are
clear the stock market on average does
better under democratic presidents now
the last couple months haven't been good
under Joe Biden
let's wait and see what happens at the
end of his term it is not always the
case but it is usually the case that
stocks do better under democratic
presidents when stocks do better 401K
accounts do better let's wait until Joe
Biden's term is actually complete we're
not even two years in at this point in
time and by the way look up all of this
stuff on your own unemployment tends to
be lower under democratic presidents GDP
growth tends to be higher job creation
tends to be higher there tend to be
fewer or there have been fewer
recessions under democratic presidents
even accounting for the difference in
number of years of democratic for
Republican presidents look it up
yourself and then ask about causation
correlation and then we can have a real
serious discussion but these confused
statements don't do much for any of us
we've got a great bonus show for you
today I'm out of time but sign up at
joinpakman.com we've got a doozy of a
bonus show for you when producer Pat
joins me